all right and we are live the last word
with lord cognito in ibotta's
friday evening campfire cool special
guest let's start with the uh co-host
first though ebay what's going on
brother how you doing
oh pretty good uh been living in the
world of um the umbrella
corporation lately for the last few days
so yeah
jump through resident evil 7 biohazard
did that over wednesday and thursday
just kind of
long stream finished it and then got
about four
and a half hours this morning i'm
probably going a little slower than like
some of the people saying it's about 10
hours but
got about four and a half hours in this
morning so um
yeah the nine foot six tall lady is
officially yeah she's tall she's big
she is she is all all of that nine foot
six and could just basically smash a
basketball goal
so which is very fitting for our guests
um so shall we shall we do this yeah
let's bring them eat
all right welcome to the last word
episode number
148 as we wrap up season of the chosen
and it looks like hunters will win the
games and officially have now
make sure that you go partake in the
closing ceremonies it's been an exciting
week of information about the future of
destiny
and we are pumped to be joined tonight
by a true legend in the community
his gaming journey started early with
the green and black gameboy
some classics we all love and some
surprise favorites along the way
gaming was a way to pass the time and
relax when he wasn't putting in the work
on the court
and this man was putting in the work so
much so he represented the gyrenes at
the collegiate level he is as sharp as
they come both on and off the court with
the master's
degree to prove it as well but all of
those brains weren't ready for the
journey taco bell was gonna send him on
over the past
seven years so hailing from florida new
york and most recently oregon
let's welcome a true sherp of the
destiny community member of gamersfirst
and tier one
who is powered by corsair elgato
logitech and advanced gg
partners on both twitch and discord the
man with the only
500 of 500 volt that matters because it
is made of gold
whose first language is actually french
and whose stream tunes are
smooth and always pleasant to the ear
just like a basketball going nothing but
net
tonight the campfire is graced by the
one and only
equation sir ek how are you doing
tonight sir
hey man i'm always chillin man thank you
very much for the invite oh man
very very happy to have you um seriously
like you've got
quite a few accolades in the world of
destiny and just life in general but
man how are you doing today what are you
been up to obviously besides of what i
saw you streaming earlier
yeah i just i just been chilling before
like the new season
um like i'll jump in and like help
people with grand masses here and there
but
it's more like just diving other things
for all the games and then when the new
season comes in
you know get ready to play it's just
it's better that way too like
you don't get the whole getting burned
out feeling
especially with vog coming and then like
the anna's six-man activity and
transmog and like this weird
pinnacle mission that's going to be like
different than what we had before so
it'll be pretty neat yeah man we got a
lot to talk about man first of all
salute to you for coming through
you know love what you're doing out here
in the community i gotta gotta start
with some gaming history first baby
because i saw some titles
that really just won oh my gosh
that i gotta start with because it is a
very contentious
debate in the final fantasy community
and i saw
the final fantasy that i wanted to see
or your gaming history
so let's talk about it man final fantasy
7 why is this so
special to you emmy but why is it so
special to you sir
i i i spent a lot of hours in that game
i would like
get off school get on the bus get home
just to play that
like it was i don't know it was just a
very big thing
uh it was different for that time too
just having all those different
abilities and having a team set up
it was just i don't know man i was i was
in the whole time
nice every time i played it nice now was
that one of your like introductions to
jrpgs
or was it just because it was i remember
in the place it was like
kind of like a spectacle at the time so
i was just like what was the
allure what kind of brought you in
actually my my friend uh he was he was
from egypt my friend nader
he had it and um you know after school
at times like i would go to his crib or
whatever
we'll play video games um during that
time we had a bunch of different games
like metal gear solid
was one of them as well but like when i
played final fantasy i was like
man i need to get this game and i you
know i didn't have the money at the time
so once he beat it he let me borrow it
nice
and then like after why i end up like i
actually gave him yu-gi-oh cards for
that game
yeah yeah i think i gave one of the like
the god cards when it came out it was
like three gods or whatever
i think i gave him like elrod or
something like that and he was like yeah
you can have it
i guess he wasn't into as much as i was
but yeah i got to like kevin and i just
kept playing it
it was one of those i don't know man
like
metal gear solid was really good for
that time it was a really hard game
but this was just like it was flashy
there were so many things going on
and before i knew it it'll be the end of
the night past my curfew i got to get in
bed
it was a game that got me in trouble but
you know it's worth it
those are the ones that like the things
that you'll like stay up late and break
the rules four tend to be the ones that
usually tend to be a little extra worth
it so yeah
i think for me real quick as well i
think was just that um i remember the
moment
for me it was the first time because
remember with the material system
so for me it was the first time i saw a
summon
like leviah my brother showed me those
what is happening like it blew
my mind that games were doing this and i
was just like yeah shout out to
he said night to the round and still
yeah that was a long summer but
but yeah like summons in general like i
never seen it it was just such a
cinematic
showcase and it just made me connect
more but um yeah
i wanted to shout you out with that
because when i saw that i was like all
right
that's final fantasy 7 there's a lot a
lot of six guys but i'm a seven guys so
i got i gotta get it
i've missed most of those but with seven
integrated coming i didn't play the
remake recently but i was like i haven't
played seven ever
which is just a giant glaring hole and i
was like oh seven and then i never got
around to because
of course where i was busy with destiny
but i was like and then ps5 and i'm like
integrate's coming i'm like oh i
i gotta wait for that so i'm gonna go 4k
60
and that's i know it's not like the the
true one and it's only a piece of it but
again if i'm gonna
start it it's gonna be pretty so i'm
looking forward to that one
i had to ask you about another one i've
never seen anybody list
or mention this game aladdin
like that is a game that i beat as a kid
nobody else says anything about that
game like
man tell me why that is on your list a
lot of it was fun to me it was just like
running around
oh you were you were jumping over things
that were like uh the little fire pits
that you got to go over
you have the carpet like it was i don't
know it was a cool disney game right
like i played it so much i failed a lot
at that game
and i kept playing it yeah no that's one
of those that
that's one of those weird platformers
and disney that i was like
actually played through and i was like i
had fun playing it like there's i mean
there's always the classic platforms but
i remember that one specifically because
i was like i'm gonna try and beat this
thing it's like
you know you rent it for like three or
four days you're trying to play it as
much as you can something like that
no it was hard but it was it was
actually well done it's kind of a little
gem that i always forget about you
mentioned that i was like
wow it's been a long time since i
haven't thought about that game it's a
good one
so it reminds me of castlevania because
i couldn't get castlevania when i was a
kid i played it a few times and then
when i got along i was like all right
cool why not
no platinum platforming's a classic of
course
um and then of course you had so he had
some rpg background he had a little
shooter background
now your choice of modern warfare is not
a typical one that we hear what makes
you specifically like
first one which one do you like because
i we know what it is but the audience
doesn't
and why that one over say some of the
others
curious okay i would the i think i
stopped that modern warfare three
three two they were all good but for
some reason when they went into black
ops and all this futuristic stuff
it just i don't know i didn't i didn't
like it oh they lost you
yeah three it was so fun man
i ran the support class and then it was
like two kills you get the
you get the map three kills you get the
ballistic vest you could drop it down
and then i had like the u.s spaz shoddy
and just run around with that
with the acr so it was just like that
was nice like you were able to like bond
trap and everything with
you know with some of this stuff and
then like the next game came out i was
like
people like jumping on walls they're
like nah this is not it
was it advanced warfare is that really
when they went wall jumping i think
was that yeah that lost me too i tried
it i'm like this is i wasn't feeling
that
titanfall did it better anyway that was
the titanfall especially it was like
that was when they were trying to catch
the titanfall wave and i was
like it just don't fit i'm with you on
that i was not a fan
like you knew they got it wrong when
they're like boots on the ground like
that's hard
it's like yeah you messed up dragon so
but no like the reason i asked is like
modern warfare
two or even one like when it went early
so that's why i was like
is it just because three is the one you
stuck with the longest like after
they kind of did that sequence is that
way like i went back and played too but
all the lobbies were just full of people
hacking
like that's quite fair yeah yeah it
wasn't funny anymore
two it wasn't that fun but three was
like the most recent so that's what they
like kept working on or like that's
where like they try to keep the cheaters
out of
yeah it was more enjoyable playing that
than it was playing too
that makes sense like i remember i went
to lobby at two people just like flying
around just shooting like fully auto i
was just like nah
can't do it i feel you bro yeah
and uh that that magical game that we've
uh come to love right
that uh that that that destiny then the
story you have told
on so many different places i heard it a
while ago on dcp
you've heard told it many places give
the quick
recap you don't need the full thing how
did you how
you got to let you got to let the people
know like how did you get into um
how did you get your playstation and
destiny it's just too good
it's a good story so i i mean when i
play college ball whatever so i
during basketball season i just try to
like stay out of trouble it's like stay
in my dorm room after practices
like two practices a day and my friend
perry
he had destiny on his playstation he
introduced me to destiny
so like i have i made my own like i i
made my i had my own account
so like i used to play on his and he
ended up like leaving the next semester
so i can't really do anything and i
remember
my roommate mike mike was like well taco
bell's like doing this giveaway thing
they have like these five dollar boxes
i was like sure why not because we we
had a drive into naples
because my campus was like it was 30
minutes away from naples i'm like that
okay
we had he was he was the guy with the
car so it was really nice
we drove there and i got one but i never
got the box
and the second time we went because we
used to go at night
uh and i told the lady i was like hey
man last time i got a you know i got
this five dollar thing but you guys
never gave me a box
but she gave me two boxes you know the
second time and i ended up winning
off of one of those three boxes so be
like can i have that extra one
it's worth a playstation thanks
i've never won any of those things right
now it's crazy because i wanted another
i wanted xbox one x
when i moved to oregon and it was
another taco bell one too but
i gave it yeah i gave it to my old
roommate because
i wasn't playing on xbox at the time and
her
her boyfriend they were sharing the same
xbox anyway so it was just like
something that she could use
yeah yeah and i mean salute that is a
tremendous story i love
stuff like taco bell know this story no
you need to be like a testimonial like a
shout out to like
my career started thanks to taco bell
like
this is a it's a weird thing but like
that that's like you could get some love
right there
taco bell for life probably you know
easy advertising man
yeah everybody looks they they need to
highlight the boy man they need they got
it they gotta get actually taco bell for
life is not gonna keep you healthy for
the athlete over here but it is
it's something you just one doritos loco
taco a day that's all you need
no doubt i was gonna ask you too is um
content creation just in general like
so now obviously playing destiny you
kind of fall in love with it
and stuff like that so it's like what
then kind of press you to say okay you
know what
i want to do this streaming thing i want
to get into the creation aspect
with destiny i was
honestly i was just i was screaming for
fun um
like my my old clan mates they used to
just play the game
and they're all streaming you know like
just we'll just be like in the play
system chat just like joking around
the hell you guys know like i'm
streaming live go check this out
and i had a not even twitch account i
think it was like i had a justin tv
account
so then it just yeah so my name just
went straight forward to twitch
because i went to go look for and i
couldn't get my name and i had forgot
password and they sent me the emails all
right cool so i do have this account
so then i you know i hooked up my my
placement account too and i started
streaming uh
it was when crota came out actually
yeah i would bring a clammy with me
we'll have two yellow horns and we just
like help kids out
with uh crota you know like they shot
their rockets out of his leg as long as
they had cluster bombs it worked anyway
and yeah we just that's when i started
streaming and
honestly i didn't take it too seriously
until
i got out of college i had a job in
florida
because my ex was from germany she had
another year
in the u.s before she graduated it
didn't really work out
and then i kind of like i don't know i
just quit my job and i went back up
north
okay and i i don't know like i i was
just playing video games because i was
like man
this is kind of weird i felt down and
i was you know i was in a weird slump
so i was like why not i was i was doing
bike messenger work
and then whenever i got home i was i
used to play video games i was like you
know what
i'm gonna start streaming again you know
see how it goes and that's when like
streaming actually started picking up
for me
um so during that time
i would like go to work come back home
then stream
and pass out and then wake up and then
go to work and
over time the channel just kind of grew
and i ended up finally getting a
partnership
so i was like man i don't i don't i
don't think i want to live in new york
i have four roommates paid this much
money oh you'd already know what i'm
doing
i'm originally from new york so i
already know that struggle that you talk
about
right there for a little small apartment
or a big apartment people got to share
because the rents are so crazy
yeah i was i was in like i was in
brooklyn the thing when i was cool too
every summer i i came back
i had to like find another place like i
lived in park slow for a bit
then came back i had to move to
williamsburg i
came back and i moved moved into best
time i was like man what the hell is
going on
right yeah like it's crazy i'm paying
like 400 a month and i have four
roommates
it's just wild i was i was looking for
like a reasonable way for me to just
like focus on streaming
and just kind of work on my channel and
maybe like have time to do youtube and
all that stuff
and i don't i don't know if you guys
know libra lebron
he was also in brooklyn we used to go to
gym together all the time
and um one of my friends risa from she
lived in oregon she had a home
and she was like well there's two rooms
if you guys want to move here i'll
charge you like
turn them out if you guys can do that
then you can stay here save up your
money and then like
move to where you want to move right so
end up just taking that
nice awesome yeah it wasn't a bad idea
because it
actually helped me focus more not salute
slow deal man that's that's not easy too
because um
especially from you know what you used
to and then also
making that shift right like just in
general you know what i'm saying and
then continuing to do it so
salute to you on that that definitely
was a power move i'd like to see that
you had stuck with it man it's very cool
yeah
yeah streaming is tough man i don't
think about it i look back at like
other people that like were streaming
around the same time trying to grow
it's not that simple you know like very
tough
yeah you might not enjoy the game that
you're playing anymore
you know but you know people that hung
around maybe their situation changed
a lot goes on you know you got to be
ready to you know work on it
oh yeah oh yeah yeah that's kind of one
of those things that destiny has
tested a lot of players kind of
willingness to be flexible
or force themselves into a burnout state
which kind of sucks on either end
because
it's not always on i mean we've loved
the gain over you know seven plus years
now and we're here for the journey and
whatever the hell else is coming
why we're doing this but also it's like
there are times and i think some of the
healthiest that it's been for me has
been in the last year
again a little bit of variety i've seen
you playing genshin and checking out
something else i've jumped onto like
resident evil it's like and if you have
a down part in a season or it's like hey
this week i've knocked out everything i
think i want to do
yeah there's a cool game coming i'm
going to jump on that for a little bit
and that has been the healthiest thing
as opposed to just living and breathing
destiny because at a point it was fresh
there was always something new like solo
nightfalls were cool stuff like that
were fun
and now like with two it's just felt
different and the ones who have tried
to live it it's harder granted i mean
like your sherping is
just on another level um i'm very
curious though is there a point
for your golden vault the 500 500 master
worked was it like
is there a point where you started to
see it accumulate and you're like okay i
might as well just put these resources
when did you decide like i'm gonna fill
it like how far in were you when you're
like
i just got to fill it up at this point
how how when did that actually like
click
i'm curious i think it was i mean it was
the season that i i put it in there
uh because you know we were doing gm
helps
and every time i i'd be like man i'm not
getting shards because you know
they put a cap on it you know i'm gonna
start master working my like because i
said again i'll just throw it in the
fall
and then my vault maybe only had like
100 things in there
and it's just slowly filling up and then
the next season was at like
400 something i was like yeah i'm gonna
have to just like
get rid of all these weapons and just
put all this gear in here until i get it
full
did you know did you lose anything to
make
that space to go for 500 jeff to get rid
of any like
kind of crucial things or pretty much no
nothing major
no it's because everything got sunsetted
so then
it was one of those things like all
right cool it's you know it's cool to
have this in the vault maybe just to
show off in the future but
it got sunset so it's not gonna do
anything for me anyway
so you know i kind of got rid of a lot
of sunset armor and weapons
and then that allowed like the whole
space to be there people like where are
your weapons i was like these are the
weapons i use all the time anyway so
like boom i'm good
yeah yeah i feel like you need probably
a very short list to actually do gm's
because
some of the big stuff is going to be
somewhat similar your anarchies and your
big stuff you'll keep around
between three characters you probably
have no space to move at all i'm
guessing so
yeah you got a favorite do you if you
had to pick a class like say for to
reppin guardian games do you have
one i mean do you have yeah it was not
about
any for guardian games
i don't know everyone's everyone's
always putting me as a hunter main
because i've done a lot more help on the
hunter
but then like this season there was like
you're warlock made man
you know you're only doing helping your
warlock i was like because that's the
class
that's needed for stuff this season like
two seasons ago
i was on my time tomorrow so just like
for me it depends on what's you know
what's happened in the game
and a lot of people will say like i'm a
mane of this and then when the season
comes around
and like you can do it easier with a
certain character i'm like
it's nice to have variety nothing wrong
with having that like bungie gave us
three slots why not just pull it up
oh yeah and then like see what you can
work with you know like they don't want
to pick between his kids
honestly i will say though in the world
of like pve
help though hunters like sometimes when
i play sometimes i feel squishy but the
invisibility especially as you're
sharping
somebody dies you need to go rhythm the
invisibility for you
it's probably huge like to use that one
i play a lot i mean i can imagine all of
them are helpful but the invisibility
for res is alone because i've been
carried to a couple gm's and been part
of that journey
and just that one clutch piece is big oh
it's huge yeah
yeah yeah that and ursa titans too man
versus titans are pretty insane you're
taking a lot of damage you're gonna get
a lot of super back
and you can just move somewhere like if
you have to move your whole fire team
people just move behind you so yeah a
lot of people call that born i was like
nah
you've got to survive right you're in a
situation where everything hits hard
how are you going to survive put up with
your head shield
for the for sure captain america times
20 kill exactly
i gotta respect it he's like i'll play
all them evenly and you take advantage
of whatever like i said the content is
hard and you notice that one
particular class really excels at eating
content then yeah then why not
me i'm just a selfish warlock
i ain't got time for all those extra
characters to salute the auto salute
i don't know how y'all do it i give you
a lot of credit though because to run
multiple classes but i will say there is
an
ease of use once you do have all three
ready you know
first one done and everything else is
kind of easier and it kind of
drops it up stuff like that so it's a
little to y'all for that is there who do
you think you'll take into
vlog first
i was i mean looking at the team concept
i'm probably going to be on my titan
just by it junior's like that's just the
six you're running with so
are you going are you going for day one
race like be part of it
yeah yeah nice nice nice nice nice
so what else we got here well i'd say we
got a whole bunch of stuff to talk about
so high level piece like because i was
actually calling it last week because
first they did like they used to do like
snippet teasers they had like 20 seconds
like tune in tomorrow or something like
that
so i was at work in the morning like all
right what are we gonna see probably
gonna cover a little bit
i'm at work like dying on the inside
because at like nine o'clock
my time they dropped it all i was like
oh
come on um yeah they put everything
around the phone though sir i got to
give you credit for the phone
you were screenshotting you oh i
screenshotted i was like i put as much
as i could i was like all right big
twitter thread here we go like this as
much as i can do from work in between
stuff that i was doing so it wasn't bad
but no
um trailer dropped got a lot of
information
high level um what are you guys excited
about the most
let's get it and then we'll go through
some details because the trailer was the
vibes
what was the vibes but you saw it i mean
there's
they got a lot coming um that's that
six-minute activity is
pretty dope um i guess i can't really
talk about it because i got to play but
like it was
oh it's pretty freaking neat exclusively
like got that community summit google
state
yeah like it's dude it's pretty fun my
only worry is like
how long is that going to be fun for
people right once you get like
your roles and what you need that's one
of the issues in destiny like
yep somehow menagerie all of it was fun
right
so it turned a stint right for a while
um
and then they have like the the pinnacle
mission is what i'm like
very interested in because apparently
it's gonna be like different things that
we have never done before
right like we're we're supposed to be
like a splicer going into a network
trying to break
into a network right so that's gonna be
different that's what i'm like
looking forward to i i know the you know
vog is there but
i play the og i feel like i fail you
know i'm gonna look forward to it but
that's not what i'm you know excited for
yeah yeah okay okay what about you cog
what's that
what's the top shout out listen man the
thing for me is
again before we get into anything shout
out to budgie on these trailers man more
often
they cannot leverage this team has so
much leverage like they can never get
fired
that's the name could be dead and buried
the walk of the team would drop a
trailer you'd be like
oh hold up
oh it's something about the music
selection just the way they hype it the
the whole process the way they put
together no one does a trail like budget
so salute to that
i was watching it i wanted to see what
the focus was obviously the leak was
season of the splicer
you know i did want to see you know if
there was on siva aspects but obviously
there's not
but um you know good to see myth racks
back in the mix you know we got baby
falling oh my god little baby falling
you know what i'm saying smalling yeah
shout out to hillary
i got the elixi kittens or elix newtons
or something like that i've seen
smallin oh man so many
so i was cool um gotta you know the
warlock delegation we have to have a
talk though um looks like
gina torres got replaced so i'm
mixed because part of me really did like
her voice acting but at the same time
i do feel for bungie that you need
someone that's consistent you know what
i mean so i don't know if her schedule
just might work out
i feel like she's probably just busy
yeah exactly
that's what i figured well big names
like that yeah yeah and they've lost
just about everybody but zavala like
lance redick is the one they're like
well we can't actually lose a volley
nobody can replace him
i will say like when we were watching
this trailer i did like
frame by frame pulled up the clip from
say like her and eris talking
yeah and there were like distinctions of
like she had a little bit more rasp a
little bit lower register her cadence
was slightly different
but i will give credit to i don't know
the actress's replacement like
she did like if i listened close i could
pick it but i was like
that was pretty damn good i was i was
impressed to be like
okay i can roll with that that's that's
close enough i i agree i
i felt like at first i didn't catch it
and then people like yo that's not right
i'm like okay
but like i said i'm always pro you know
someone who can
be consistent who's you know schedule
wise you know it can can do the job so
i'm for that so that was that
obviously six-man activity huge for me
you know because
you know i'm a fan of sundial i'm a fan
of menagerie and to me
nothing's worse than destiny when you
got a whole bunch of people on and it's
like all right
we got to break up the team y'all you
got to go over here because it's just
and not everybody does raid and let's be
honest in the state of pvp not everybody
doing banner
these days so they have a six you know
player pve
vlog is my heart so i seen that facts
all the good stuff that all the
nostalgia
i am what you ek said i'm curious though
what these pinnacle missions are that is
a very
interesting thing i want to see how they
approach it but yeah over
overall man i was excited and then
narratively i just want to see
how they put the ball the transition now
from you know season of the chosen into
season for spicer
you know what happens with the hokkaido
thing what happens with crow
you know and how they transition and
then shout out to you know finally you
know
cyrus and nicora having dialogue since
all this
this craziness yeah so yeah i'm excited
man i'm excited
it's a lot to look forward to and i'm
curious about e like what you thought i
thought
you know what was the vibes why are you
at work on the phone going crazy
i mean like they started pretty great
like vex might have been a speculation
it was like splicer was in there i was
like
kind of curious how that was gonna play
together it's cool to see mythrax back
he's been
uh milan games was actually on dcp and
he's been talking about
he was basically just an easter egg in a
mission on the moon like if you didn't
kill him or not you had that little
different ending and then he helped us
in zero hour and it's been this
you know fallen kell like splicer guy
sacred place where we now know now
slowly building in the background and
actually see
us working with the fallen us working
with the cabal
i mean the whole idea of like you know
kind of the avengers coming together to
face whatever witch queen could bring
seems like it's now actually getting to
be a bit more potential
if you know the splicer technology can
take some of the vex technology
and help us fight whatever's coming like
the idea behind
all of this coming together seems really
cool so that piece was
really cool um i don't know i'm very
curious we were joking in my chat like
if they just put like the earth in a
dome how it's all night time the whole
time
just like how it's actually how whatever
they said a vex simulation and i'm
wondering
so it does simulation of night time and
the earth is just in a dome
sunlight moon on both sides we're seeing
either so i'm wondering how they
actually kind of explain that if they do
um but the one for me and my big
speculation i'll get to a little bit
later i'm with ek
the mission for me the pinnacle mission
and exotic pinnacle mission may have an
exotic in there it would be a
proper place for them to probably put it
um that's what i'm most excited about
six man activities i'm with both of you
guys we're like they're cool they're fun
but also he's like you know seven weeks
in as we have a three and a half month
season this time we'll get to the length
of the season later
after a while like anything you're like
yeah i've done my 100th
it's cool like i got i got the field you
know we're gonna have it on three
planets
we got 15 16 weeks to a season it's just
gonna be in the rotation
but as there are six they they
specifically list it six times so it's
either
yeah right so is it like
six different variations six different
story
you know beats that go along with it and
what i wanted to ask you guys i guess
i'll just jump in now because this has
been my speculation since i did my video
when i got home
let's go the timing of when it starts
now part of me wants to like second
guess myself of the way they list vault
of glass
in the twab as a legend activity
but if there is any story implication to
vault of glass
and this mission
because vault of glass comes on saturday
and this starts
the following reset so in theory like in
chronological terms
will beat the raid will beat atheon
supposedly but the thing
they show screenshots of like three guys
running into what looks like this
mission
and the emblem on the chest the look of
like the points and everything
it looks like a weird variation or
something very close to atheon
i've never seen like the symbol on
atheon's chest
is the exact same one in that mission so
i'm wondering if we're like going into
the next
vex network like chasing him between
different things like if vault of glass
kicks off this mission
that would be cool now getting my
expectations too high of course i
shouldn't do it
but timing-wise i'm still wondering if
there's some implication of vault of
glass
into this mission and if so that's
actually pretty cool but i don't have a
clue but like
timing wise it has me wondering why it
starts
two weeks later why it starts after the
raid and why this guy in this
three-person mission
looks like atheon's chest
yeah any anything i feel like
right now what they're doing with the
story like they're aligning everything
pretty well
um even with like mint rights coming in
i mean the tower is gonna be fun for
people when they get there next season
but like there's just so many different
things that they're putting in
and i feel like what you just said might
be true we might be being vaulted glass
and then it
lines up but then perfect example
glassway a lot of people said
um last season that we're getting vog
this season because
the last way the portal there is how
we're going to get into the vault of
glass
because if you switch it around it's the
way to the vault of glass instead of
glassway
so everyone's like you know putting that
together so now you're saying like you
know
this mission is going to come out after
we beat it that might be true as well
there's so many like things that bungie
just puts in and sets and stone and
people like
wait what if what about this what about
that like theory crafting
like whoever makes their like their
stories and their
their lore is just insane because you
just go through so many
like rabbit holes like you don't know
what's coming up yeah
like wife eats that's like that man
they can dive deep deep in the rabbit
holes but it's cool for them to have
both of their knowledge of it to say hey
where the so was like i was listening to
him and he talked about
i forgot about the moon easter egg with
mythrax and like bringing him
full circle all the way around is really
cool to see come in but
yeah the the exotic missions have lately
been my favorite i don't do as many
raids
grand masters i do obviously nobody does
this as much as you i don't think with
2200 under your belt um
but no the exotic missions are still my
favorite between the story and
everything they do in there and if
there's like
six parts to this thing that's that's
probably where i'm definitely excited
about
yeah yeah was really nice um
i felt like we were going to guess
something like that the previous season
because i was talking to biff he's like
what are you talking about i was like
look at the hunter gauntlets from this
season it was like
what what hunter garland's and then we
were we started talking about it like on
screen i was like
what the hell you guys talking about
like don't worry about it
you're like yo they like you know
they're they're taking scorn up on
like you know callous ship like we don't
know what the hell is going on
but it's cool that this season when you
open up the last compartment
they have the crown of sorrows boss
helmet in there
and that's what like control the scorn
but like i didn't even know that that
was even in the lore so there's so many
like hidden things that like
when it just lines up they'll put like
little hints here and there
and you'll never pay attention unless
like looking at the gear so now every
season i'm like looking at like
lauren gear like hmm like what does that
say you know like you just never know
what little nugget's gonna be like oh
what's this say and i remember exactly
because i was actually talking with my
chat and they're like hey go look at the
hunter arms the gauntlets and go read it
and it says you know callus is doing and
because it's got the full lore paragraph
on some of those now and it's the one
line saying like callus is doing like
going around sucking up all the scorn
and i was like holy and then yeah you
were you guys were
dead on so yeah the way they do some of
the lore and building is
crazy and just to keep it all straight
more power to the the big lore
people narrative team's been on fire
with that stuff lately
yeah the story has been really good
that's like that's what has me excited
for the rest of this whole
decade absolutely uh so so yeah we got
you know the vex basically plunged the
last city into an endless knight
we got mythrax coming in he's the sacred
splicer he can actually
you know combat vexology technology
technology because
he's got some bond with light he's got
some understanding of x technology he's
a
surprising fallen ally um and speaking
of that we're gonna have some fallen
hanging out in the helm
so we actually get an upgrade to the
helm we get to go down you know in the
basement a little bit hang out with what
looks like a servator hanging from the
rafters and
uh it feels like we've got um
another hammer of proving coming because
you're gonna have ether to charge up
this like splicer gauntlet
same way you have cabal gold to charge
up the hammer
you're gonna have different things that
you can do with the gauntlet it's
probably going to be like
leveling up the splicer gauntlet at the
servitor so i i wondered i want to ask
you guys if it is really similar to
um the hammer almost it sounds almost to
a t but maybe not exactly the same
are you ready for one of those bad
back-to-back seasons or is that going to
be a bit of a
like kind of unnecessary grind i wanted
to see your guys thoughts about that
what'd you think ek um i mean that was
like my initial thought
when they first introduced that right um
but i they're they made it a little bit
different
than what we have the previous season
because
i remember complaining about having to
go charge
then going and doing activity then
getting something then going back to the
helm to even like turn that in and then
like having a helm
be part of the tower like i mean matter
of fact they also moved the node
out of the tower to his own thing now so
like
it seems like they're taking feedback
and trying to work on it
but some of it i feel like some of it
was already put into place before we
even get to get feedback
right so i'm hoping that the next season
a little bit different
yeah the the the whole like uh falling
in the
you know in the helm stuff like it's
there's gonna be memes man like even at
the tower like
it's gonna be me what is it oh i didn't
even think about like emoting with a
fallen guy or something like that oh
that's going to be bad
one that was one i was laughing at heart
and i feel like people were going to
find that the first day like
yo
but i mean it's cool that we're finally
working with the fallen
who were like you know people that like
the traveler kind of left behind
there's and there's a lot of myths going
out going on now too because
you know people were talking about like
maybe the travelers might leave us
because we went with the fallen or
something like that
and so on and that's why like life fall
might happen and i'm like
i don't know i feel like you were
thinking way too far i'm trying to look
for like
lauren gear that says anything about
witch queen but not really like
light fall light falls like all the way
back there yeah
that's real far that's 20 23 it's gonna
be a minute
yeah yeah it's just to see the cool to
see the helm get upgraded
[ __ ] yeah nah i like it man i like it i
mean you know it seemed
to me the vibe i'm getting is the home
depending on how far they go out with
the seasons that that might be the
seasonal
activity spot as far as like where you
congregate to do things the only thing
is i agree with okay like
i don't know if i necessarily want every
season to follow that structure of like
how the hammer went
you know what i mean so i'm curious to
see how they handle that um
i do like the idea narratively of them
in a spot like a base of operations okay
this is the new threat this is what's
going on
that kind of thing i do like that all
the cool the little
somebody had a little v was like yeah
like
nintendo power oh yeah that was
that's that's the one for sure it was
black burn i was black but i think that
did
yeah so it's just look at them you know
i'm curious with the whole vex
you know involvement and stuff like that
and obviously hacking the network and
the override thing so
yeah my whole thing is i want them to
continue the narrative
beats that they did like with um season
of the children where you go in there
and
you're getting i want them to continue
that multiple voice acting thing
i like now when you go in there silence
says this osiris says this and
zavala says this because to me it made
the world feel alive like
i like that feeling like there's a
universe going on and people connected
and the other thing is
um definitely crow i want to know what's
going on i don't want them to just
completely go away from him
i want to know what he's doing during
this period i was like that's honestly
my worry
right now is because the closing
ceremony had nothing if you guys haven't
seen paul tassie's 20 second video it's
hilarious
um but it feels like this season
unless they do some cinematic of they
have if they don't tie this thing up at
all
if it's just like week seven okay we had
the thing here's your dagger
scion ran off and then we just start the
next season
pro sitting somewhere with like nothing
to do and then you've got
title an ally for the next three and a
half months but we're not gonna have any
actual interaction that's always like
the weird pieces and i know it's hard
for them to
as they're like okay we need to tell the
i-corps and the vex story to build up
this piece
but if there's no connection to the
other do they do feel like they're
trying to build some blocks
but man they are not connected sometimes
and it's like i'm with you it's like i'd
like to see
i need a transition whether it be like i
said you know end of the season
you know i mean right before the recess
something needs to happen in my opinion
to transition it but yeah that's where
i'm at with it but other than that yeah
that looks cool to help him upgrade
stuff
yeah we need to see some kind of
cutscene
but i would say this is like the first
time even in destiny history that we
like
see allies actually like moving
into like places that we're at
you know like it's the first time you
you're like wait a minute this is like
this is not an enemy this is like an
ally that's like in
our helm spot right now like yes even
with the cabal this season we didn't
really have cabal like here we went to
their spot
right now so it's gonna be it's gonna be
weird
i don't i don't even know if like the
because you know the traveler like
changes sometimes right i wonder if like
anything's going to happen to travelers
as well
you know i'm thinking about that whole
again what is it they blocked out the
sun like what what is the vex doing
yeah the simulation putting us in an
inter like in endless
lit by like moonlit moonlight something
like that i'm not reading it right now
but
yeah it's this weird simulation where
we're only covered in moonlight
so the sun won't rise is what i chorus
says at one point i think so
no i was gonna say the last part i'm
gonna say was what you said
which is the coolest part i think is
allying with these races that we've been
enemies with for so long yeah right
so it is if they do it right but you
don't mess this up if y'all do what is
right
we could have some avengers tight
moments bro like again like it would
come
all in in the falling and stuff like
that i'm very curious man to see where
this is going because there's a lot of
loose threads
that they got potential to connect into
like a really cool story
yeah well keeping us occupied we talked
about overwrite that's the six player
matchmade activity says fire teams of
six will use splicertech to hack the vex
network uncover their secret steal their
code and use their powers against them
we're gonna have that on europa the
tangled shore and the moon seems like
the three locations over the first three
weeks we're gonna get that one
that one seems because you can see it on
the patrol zones basically you'll see
like
different pictures of where it's on
tangle shore you can see where it's on
the moon
and then it also shows them very much
inside the vex network as well in this
little like you know
looks like tron blocky that's all i keep
hearing everybody talk about so i can't
not say it
yeah so it's just like so it feels like
we're gonna
unlock some the network outside wherever
which locations on
and then potentially go inside the
network because there's like the team of
six people running through the tron area
so it feels like we start on the outside
go on the inside do some activity which
i think should be fun
because getting six people together i
don't expect raid level mechanics but it
definitely should be more
as long as it's not like corrupted
mechanics that people just can't pick up
for some reason the balls are are a bit
of a struggle
so we got we got we got protected oh no
no i get it i got you i got you
he's just over there like
we've done that like a lot of people
pick up on quick okay like
yeah okay but yeah those are
i mean so it's been five five
it'll be a fifth season since because
last one is sundial which was dawn
it's a long time since we've had a six
player and then menagerie
so i mean you had two and then you had
like every other season and then we went
this is the five seasons away so it's a
chunk so i mean people have been waiting
for a while
and i feel like they're kind of coming
into
a little more consistency in what they
can deliver because now we got a
six-player match made
we had you know the the exotic missions
are pinnacle now
those are becoming a little more
consistent because they've now announced
this one beforehand it's not like a
secret that they're hiding
which i don't know if i love because i
was like the reveal the first day like
destiny twitter just explodes me like
there's a new mission like those moments
are always really cool
so it's kind of weird that they would
announce it which is why i always find
that one a bit strange
um but we talked about the mission um
that one is gonna start on week three
then four five six seven and eight are
the ones they listed on
i don't imagine it's gonna actually go
away but it is
apparently six weeks at least listed on
the calendar that we've got
so we'll have to see what's going on
there and then
they did it vlog went
free i wanted i was like we were
literally talking about this last
episode i was kind of curious
when you saw that it was free what you
thought sir
man listen you know this is
obviously i'm biased but this is the
crown jewel so
you know for reprise content i was
curious to see how they was going to
handle it right i was going to see like
okay
are they going to treat this like a
pinnacle activity where this is a
premium thing and you have to be a part
of the season
and i think this is smart i think this
is small i think you you want
everybody to play this activity you want
people invested
you know again i'm on console xbox
primarily
to have people say hey i didn't have to
buy the season and i can do this
and i can jump in the vault and this is
let's be honest like this is their
premiere thing i know for the for the
hardcore for the vets we like yeah been
there done that
but this is the pre-med thing for a lot
of people especially people
who've went away from destiny you're
going to get a lot of people that's
going to like yo
you know what i mean fog is bad all
right i'll try it you know i don't have
to pay
i mean you know what kind of thing yeah
i think it's smart i think you get the
most people in this activity they handle
it
really good free to play is a great idea
and then
i'm also hyped about the um engagement
with worlds first because they did a
real good job with the saturday date
with uh deep stone i thought that was
smart stick with that
now you're free to play they could get
some record engagement man i'm very
curious to see
how many teams and the clears and all
that stuff what'd you think aka like how
how do you think it was a good move i
mean i felt like it was a good move
because
here's the thing it was something that
we paid for in destiny one
but that's if you play destiny one right
but it's new content for destiny 2
players
but at the same time you can't really
charge someone to play the same thing
that they already paid for
in a previous thing is is it cool to
play on like
you know the next gen or even on pc
hell yeah but there was no way they were
going to
be able to like resell that to the
community like oh
we're selling you this as new old
content
yeah yeah there was there was no way
good point
like yeah even if they bring back raf or
king's fall or crota whatever it is
you can't sell that to people you know
because a lot of
like a majority of the players are
veterans that play destiny one
so like you trying to tell that bag
would be like a spit in the face you
know i mean
especially when like there's a seasonal
model with new stuff coming in all the
time
that could be paid for you know like you
know the six minute activity
this pinnacle mission all these new
exotics that's
i mean like it sells itself you know
like they make
they make some cool exotics like like
the thought concepts behind them were
just insane even like denman cells was
like
like whoa like this gun is fun like wait
why is this gonna feel different you
know like the first time i got i was
like
what this scout okay feels weird you
know and then you get the galaxy like
whoa
yes that is good so
it still blows my mind every time when
they come out of the concert for a
weapon or even the pressage mission yep
i was sick of like
you know grabbing the ball and charging
it or sitting on a plate
this one had like you know you shooting
spores and go through stuff like
bro that's what i'm saying it's hard to
come up with a new concept
a game that's been out for so long yeah
you know
good point and a lot of people sit there
there matter of time give us new content
i was like
have you thought of an idea what to do
yeah you know like
talk to me a lot of armchair developers
talk to them you know people talk about
oh i don't want to do most anymore
i don't want to do you know charging the
ball anymore but like what are you going
to make you know
it's not that simple every game has
mechanics
you know no you're on fire brother i
think that is a fantastic point because
that was something i always thought
about like just working for the studio
and you've got this ravenous fan base
that always wants something new and they
picked up the content
fast right so you not only do you have
to create new stuff all the time
but because the consumer consumes it so
fast
you've got to be quick so it's it's a
tough it's a tough boat to be that's why
i don't really go crazy anymore
you know what i'm saying thanks to e he
calm me down you know say over the years
but yeah but at the end of the day
that's a great point you know
for them to keep continually for what is
it six years now how long have we been
doing it's like
this is a long time for destiny
continually to come up
with new stuff all the time new
mechanics
lore missions pressage all these things
we talk about zero out all these great
things that
we kind of get spoiled with how good
they
are i feel like i mean they're the one
gladiator sitting
left in the ring after all the destiny
killers came calling
yeah i was like yeah none of them have
survived and destiny is still
trucking building a you know two and a
half times bigger studio and staff and
everything else that they're doing with
this franchise alone
that they you know bought themselves out
from activision
now there are decisions when it comes to
like transmog
yeah you can have your thoughts either
way on that one we expressed our
opinions with travis the other day as
like you know when we were on
we just went absolutely off on it and
that's one of those decisions where
you're like
i understand there's business besides it
but also some of the veterans you feel
kind of screwed so like there are times
where you get the give and take i
understand some business but
there are it's like they deserve a lot
of credit for what they
do manage to put out on such a basis
that's like
what you get for ten dollars every three
months
no one else is doing that like even
world of warcraft they might do a big
ass expansion but it would be like
when they would do an expansion it's
like two years and we still get a decent
sized expansion one year seasons every
three months
or four whatever this cadence is going
to be for the delay but we get
a fair chunk out of a studio that's you
know
now doing its own thing completely
independently so no i completely agree
it's like they deserve some credit
nobody's perfect because yeah we'll
definitely call them when they're you
know making bad decisions and
the community summits secret people get
to go to hopefully get to be like
all right so got some opinions here and
there's going to be a little give and
take in those hopefully because i mean i
heard long ago i think when we started
the podcast it was near one of the early
ones around curse of osiris and it's
like
there were some things you heard that
like hey they pitched this idea and they
turned around changed it the next day
like
sometimes the feedback is good but on
the other side sometimes it's
you know sometimes the gamers don't know
what they want until the developer gives
it to him
which is like hey you and that's like
you know super mario and anything else
like that's been going on for a while
but then there's sometimes it's like
yeah you got this wrong so it's always
interesting to watch the journey but
destiny's the only one that's got the
longevity
versus anything else and it's it's a
good thing to actually be part of it
and that's like that's why we're talking
about vault of glass being free just
this is one of those like perfect
there is no free raid and i think this
also kind of tells
how vault of glass is going to be vault
of glass as their first raid is not like
last wish
there's no penumbral and tumbra there's
no crazy vault mechanics you're not like
so it's not going to be to the crazy
mechanic level but if it's like
you know new guys first raid and it's
their chance to
understand the mechanics have some you
know destiny to you know paint on it and
let somebody get in
without because they said they're going
to kind of embrace
most of the theme of it with giving you
you know get some new destiny to
polish i think it's going to be a great
way for new players to understand
not and like if you take someone in the
last wish for the first time that's a
little much
just did that oh god i just did that i
took rand outdoor shout out to randall
thought him
listening i just took it but i was
paying cause like just you know you got
to teach them again i just want to enter
a
party because you're on fire um also
the fact that the no light requirement
right because 1300
they're right in and and it's very
significant because
i almost quit destiny if it wasn't for
fall if it wasn't for vaulted glass
i would have quit because my friend was
like yo you got to get to level 30.
and i'm like i already end this game i
don't know what y'all talk about like i
was kind of done right
and then the story as a story goes like
when i got there and i'm okay i was of
level to do it and think about that
percentage of people who
never who gave up on destiny never
experienced it you know i'm saying
regardless how people feel about vault
being the best rate or not
that's opinion but we can't deny the
significance of when people
found it and like yo they got something
this is special
so why i love is that there's going to
be no light requirement for the
for the new guy so to speak right now
1300 it's not bad
he could get in and he can at least try
the thing that they may have missed out
on with d1 so that's the part i'm really
excited about
ek any thoughts about vogue are you just
like kind of ready to kick its butt
again
do you how do you think they're going to
change that i guess the best question
because you're probably the well
the most recently versed on it if you've
done any d1 playing and stuff like that
how do you think they'll actually make
like changes to it
champions do you expect wyvern like
anything crazy pretty close what do you
go
i'm thinking more than likely champions
maybe the maze might be different
uh templar encounter you might have to
be down there
when you're doing oracles and stuff like
that you know
it might be like joining allies if you
try to chill up top um
yeah and that's the thing too they might
add in like you know some extra like
little loopers right you know uh extra
enemies coming out somewhere
there's definitely going to be something
because we had champions and raids
before
yeah our gos was probably one of the
first ones that had it
so we'll definitely see how bad it is
they might not make it too hard just
because i know
what they're doing the whole challenge
thing once you beat it then there's
another thing to do so
we'll see we'll see what the what the
challenges are going to be
um but i don't really see them changing
too much everyone's like
maybe the harpies are gonna become
wyverns
who knows that'd be spicy
but yeah you did say it though like june
may 22nd it launches
june 15th they have the raid challenges
which i guess is going to be
what the raid race has is my assumption
of how that's going to be yeah
and then july 6 they have the difficulty
options which is
probably the longest it's been years
since we've had raid
difficulties and they're bringing i
guess a raid master coming in
um do you guys see anything like
adept vog weapons or how do you guys see
the rewards going for
because if somebody's going to make me
say hey i can go run vog or i can go run
master vlog why am i going to go run
master
what do you guys think they're going to
go reward wise when it comes to the top
dog of
you know raids now i think they spoke
about that though they spoke about
um going into activities that have a
massive version of them same thing for
dungeons
and uh you know possibly having like not
just a depth weapons of a depth armor as
well
it was it wasn't 12 maybe like a month
ago and they were talking about that
so you know if that thing is coming out
a lot later maybe that's what they're
setting up
yeah could be i would i would just so i
just love that they're going back to
that i always felt d1
had that advantage with the raise with
the challenges because you you just
extend more life
in the content and i always feel rated
some of the best content so
when they bring these challenges back
and then with the world first isn't it
like a
these secret parameters that you have to
yeah it's like a set of challenges per
activity if you fail it you
wipe like the way i guess you have to
you have to beat the raid once on
contest
and then you'll go back in on challenge
mode which is probably contest plus to
have to do it certain ways
right so it seems like yeah you're gonna
have to at least go through twice
minimum
yeah which will be interesting so i'll
be very curious i won't be trying to win
the race but i think cog and i might
have to jump in at least try and beat it
once at least see how that one goes um
but yeah honestly i i don't really
usually talk about the rewards
but i gotta ask cog are you gonna buy
this ring
yo you know that's me actually
i'm gonna tell you a secret i wouldn't
care about the jack i don't like the
jack i don't like the arms on the chair
like i actually kind of like it because
it's clean black on the outside the arms
aren't too much but the inside looks
awesome the inside looks like it looks
like it's fine i just don't like the
loose
poofy arms i want like the you know some
type of
do you want like the elastic like bomber
jacket sleeve is that what you want
something to hold on to i don't like the
loose oh i don't know it's just me
anyway the ring i was like i got to get
that ring for
got that like i'm a vlog hardcore
flow i have to have like life is not
complete
till i get that break so i'm in there
day one whatever i got to do
to get raised triggers yeah there you go
ray string is iron tight i feel you
like i need something man make those
arms look a little a little tighter
put them down man i'm definitely doing
that that that's a go
all day every day yeah i saw the design
on the outside with like the atheon kind
of like shape and like the weird
probably a little like
light vest in the middle just i was like
i was like
if cog doesn't get this i'm gonna be
full this is you written uh you are vog
if anything has vlog like
you have to order the jacket i mean you
gotta go full vlog but you know
i was hoping for a shirt i wanted like a
like
yeah but i have more t-shirts because
i'll wear them i'm with you on that one
yeah
sure like you know what i mean but you
know what
that
you're going to be up to guardian con
and be like blink
so of course they got armor synth we'll
blow past that we've talked about that
plenty we probably all have
um i will say the look of the loom
um they did a really cool job
taking something visually to be like
yeah this actually looks like a
synthetic crazy
exo bloom it looks kind of i mean if you
turned all those strings to red it would
look like siva
but for white it looks like a loom um so
they did a cool look for her area
um before we get to weapons though and
some of the other stuff that's coming i
wanted to actually ask you guys because
i saw one thing cool they did for free
people
the six player matchmade activity now
they have a week to try it
the free trial on override um they've
never done anything like that to my
knowledge correct
i think that's new i don't know
yeah i thought that was a cool thing
because you get the raid you get the arm
synthesis
you get the basic stuff that's free but
it's like hey here's the six person
thing
you get a week to try and see if you
like it do you get the weekly pinnacle
mission no because you got to pay for
them to build that but you know the
patrol activity that's a little less
resource intensive
pre-trial i thought that was actually
just a cool touch that they did
i agree i agree um okay so let's talk
weapons
and exotic armor ek what stands out to
you for like what's one of the first
things you want to try
that you know is coming um
i don't know there's i mean there's a
lot of weapons coming i i wouldn't i
kind of want to
see what the new perks are like what the
newport combos are going to be
every season there's like new perks that
come in and they're pretty awesome
and then like the depth weapons coming
in
i saw the scout the sniper and then
the fusion right so like i you know i
want to know what they put on those
things like what can we like
roll on that because that mods that they
put out have been pretty insane like
the big ones all of all those mods are
like game changing right so then
i wonder if we're gonna have like maybe
shoot salute on that you know like
that online sniper just i just like i
just want to know
what can come in that can change the
game a little bit because every season
they'll put in perks and people like
don't really pay attention to them
like left from gold is like one of those
perks something like especially last
season when we had spores of war
i always had special ammo i never had to
run finder whenever i found heavy
i had special right so it was like the
best thing in the world
and they put in more perks like that
that people like
slowly don't pay attention to like wait
a minute why using that why using that
perk and also oh that's why using that
perk
that's crazy so i hope that they do that
more
and i like the look of the weapons man
it reminds me of like
uh the whole sundown stuff too like
somehow weapons were completely
different
the whole scene 14 thing and then like
even the warm wine weapons had like
this warm line feel to them so like them
bringing the splicer thing in and then
like having the gear
looking uh fallen thing and then the
weapons look
like that too i i love that man and i
know people always talk about reskins
but
those things are not reskins those are
like brand new like
effects and it's hard to do that in most
games like any game you play most of the
time
the gun is going to be a reskin i don't
think anyone can like name a game that
like
oh this is a brand new gun from like out
of nowhere
nah man it's not that easy to design a
gun and make it look completely
different from someone else
yeah you know and they consistently do
it it's a
good point because um a lot of these
kind of i remember like i said season of
dawn and how
high those look you know what i mean the
aesthetic and these these are in that
same bag and
i ain't gonna lie i was happy to see
that hung jerry though
that's why i was like oh that's a cycle
what is it um what you call it the irene
r is it the irene rr4 is that the one
everyone's saying is they use the maki
i don't know yeah it was the mayor
whatever yeah i know what you're talking
about the thing is when you look at
the iron one the the site is different
on the user mario and the irene
right now so i don't know um
i mean bungie will confirm it but
i actually really it i've really always
enjoyed the amalan snipers and i'm
probably
odd man out because they actually have
very very low aim assist if they stick
to how they used to be
but i always for some reason really
enjoyed how it felt when i hit those
shots between
the sound effect of like the omalon
weapon on a sniper
and just like if it was low aim
assistant i hate it i was like i'm not
great at sniping but at least i know i
actually hit that one so it was like
something about the online sniper now my
question about hung jury
let's go everybody's hyping it up scouts
aren't in the best spot
right now depending on like what perks
and stuff on
aim assist bluff i mean that's the whole
thing but
scouts serve purposes if they need to be
like champion killers and stuff like
that you can use them
theoretically it could have some fun
perks which is what could set it apart
being adept maybe
but again we have seen decent amount of
the sandbox stuff and scouts aren't
getting touched and they still
overall i don't love them in pvp or pve
generally i don't know i know it was a
great in pvp
or pve before in d1 absolutely used that
thing for way too many years
but i was like i don't know if it's
going to hit quite the same way because
of where scouts are right now that's
just the one like
just save your guys expectations is all
i'm trying to say it may not
quite may not quite get there it's just
my only worry so
i mean i'm with ek though i think the
key is gonna be
because we know they're doing new perks
yeah and i would ek the sense of
perk combinations if even if scouts stay
where they are
if they could get some new perks and
newport combinations that you confuse
with that you can get on these weapons
then that might set it apart with a
different play style but i'm with you i
know what the expectation in which
scouts are what's that fusion though i'm
curious i've heard it called a couple
different things like 77 wizard i don't
even know if that's
it's the plug one um oh i i
i thought it was the light beware and
then someone went and like got me like a
picture of the plug
and i was like okay cool so it's not the
light be where it's actually the plug
one
um yeah but even going back with the
hung jury if the
i think the hung jury's gonna be a
lightweight scout lightweight scouts
actually feel
really nice especially omelette ones yes
because here's the thing menenden
was also an ominous yeah a towel rifle
and that thing shredded
bananas was really strong and i for some
reason i thought they were gonna bring
it back they never brought it back or
even the
the future wall caught one i thought
that was gonna come back that never got
brought back
so if they bring back hung jury
especially as a lightweight omalan that
thing is going to shred
now the lightweights those are the 200s
or 260s correctly i forget which one i'm
wrong i
think they're two hundreds two hundred
feet nine because that's like night
watch right
yeah yeah yeah yeah night watch is the
light one as well okay um
one of the scouts that felt really good
that guy sunset was the sundial one
i use that thing i think it's insane so
like
hopefully it brings that same kind of
feel um
i like perfect example people love
trustee but trustee is a rapid fire
yeah uh that's that's the same slot is
the the crucible and i forgot the name
of it right now
uh the pinnacle one too critical one
yeah that went away
um i forget well we're really good at
podcasting
my bad it was it was randy or something
like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah trusty is like
the same as randy's but
hung jury's going to be completely
different um
but if it's a lightweight man it's going
to be good uh if they make a high impact
it's going to suck
high impacts yeah
yeah no high impact high impact autos
they're hitting the 450s with a little
bit of a change like one level bump
for i think pvp at least based at but
yeah high impacts which still feel
terrible 360 autos not touched i'm like
i think the only thing you got because
almost like
they i feel like they know if they like
touch anything on high impacts
they're going to break yup that's good
it's like it's too
strong so if you give it any buff it's
too much
yeah cause think about this in crucible
someone can basically
three tap you from far and have a lot of
anuses no one's ever gonna like
get close-up fights right
that's why i know the scouts don't do
too well like you know medium range
anymore because in destiny one
you grab visual confluence that's the
same thing as a hand cannon it does the
same thing as a hand cannon
you don't need a cannon because that
thing had range but you could use it up
close
it's like you're trying to balance it
it's weird though
i don't know they've gone out their way
to specifically say
they're not going to like embrace that
gameplay like they've gone out away from
the distance and
and scout so when i saw the aim
assistant i said okay that's probably as
far as they're gonna go with it
but i agree they're definitely making a
hard line stance
with the with the uh what's called
aggressive the extra powerful
autos and all that stuff i think is um
messenger isn't that
heavy an
yeah but the pulse rifles the pulse
already got some love yeah
the only one that let you rock yeah yeah
the high impacts got some love they can
like to tap if you hit everything
yep yeah
one of the seasonal weapons because you
got
on the the fallen looking like the same
as kind of the crazy armor with like the
silver and the pink and green going on
you've got top right if we're getting an
exotic sidearm which we will talk about
here in a second i don't know if that's
another sidearm or a hand cannon
i can't quite tell where that's going to
fall i kept saying sidearm but
i don't know that's the sidearm okay
from the yeah before okay it kept
looking like a sidearm i'm like would
they do two sidearms but apparently
um top left is that a grenade launcher
of sub
grenade launcher yeah do you okay so
we've got the one down
okay i guess sorry not down it looks
like it's going to be a kinetic grenade
launcher that's what it looks like
oh please please i want one of those
really bad
because we've got the one that looked
like it fell out of iron banner but it's
going to be the vanguard one coming with
the um
cruiser yeah because that one looked
like an energy one looks it looks just
like
you know like you said like the the ib
one but the one up top
it looks like it's going to be connected
if i could get a kinetic i have
fun with those and people probably hate
me in pvp when i use them like salvage
or salvo
i just have fun because like trying to
do the geometry bounces and stuff like
that i have a good time
but also with the explosions like chain
reaction and stuff i enjoy as well and
that one for pve
like throwing a bunch of like four or
five guys and just gonna let them go so
i'm terrible with that gun i don't know
what it is i my aim is the worst no i
will tell you
horrible er earning mountaintop through
the real quest line
trained to me to be better straight up
like that
that was the only good thing about that
is now i was like i'm not perfect by any
means but i was like i
got a decent feel of like the hold time
for travel and that was just practice
that's all it was
um okay which exotic are you guys pumped
about for armor
they all have potential i think but
which one do you guys is there any
you're scared about is there any you're
excited about
exotic armor because all right i can
read them all
star eater scales allows hunters to
feast on orbs charging their super more
quickly and making it more potent
the ba the path of burning steps titan
armor that converts solar eliminations
into increased weapon damage
makes them more difficult to lock down
with stasis boots of the ambassador
condenses a warlock's rift healing
or empowering energy into projectiles
that seek out their allies and
bless them with noble benefits so
ek which one which one do you want which
one's the most exciting to you
if i look at all three i would say
probably the warlock one stands out just
because
when it like your your riff whether it's
healing or empowering
it's going to basically do the same
thing as luna it's going to shoot out a
little thing that tracks your allies
that might be getting end game whether
it's pve or pvp
um the titan boots is kind of neat
because there's any solar elemental
kills
basically keep you away from like maybe
getting frozen and stasis
that might be good in crucible but my
thing is
a lot of titans are not taking off doom
archers to be honest with you we're for
movement
like movement matters a lot in destiny
and that's one of the things
that do marches kind of does and then
the melee
chaining so i don't really see that
taking over too much
um and then the hunter
like the hunter has so many good exotics
that i don't really know how much
damage that's going to do because it
requires you to pick up orbs first
right and then to stack it it almost
reminds me of uh
i think storm dancer's brace the wall
like chess piece like when you pop
and you kill something you get to do
more damage it doesn't even last long
enough for you to stack it up to five
to do damage to a big thing so like i
feel like those boots are
probably going to be useless as well
when it comes to the hunters so
the warlock boots are probably like the
main thing that i see like
possibly working there you know like you
know six-minute activity someone has
that on
and like oh man i'm one shot all of a
sudden something just comes up and hits
you with you
hearing me like that seems like it'll
work in both aspects of the game
tv or pvp a lot better than the other
two let me ask you this
aka about the wall you think is gonna be
subclass specific or do you think it it
doesn't matter and it like
do you think it'll be tied to solar
class like
you think it'll be no why would it be
nope right and then
it just said rift it said healing or
empowering so
that's exciting because that's true
support it reminds me of um
the illumina right in the sense that
lumina would shoot out and seek out
so basically i put a rift down and then
it's going to seek out for
either the empowering or the that's
pretty
good for high-end content i am curious
though with the um
the titan how much weapon damage
that's i love my solar titan i just do
like
pvp i'm better throwing cameras that
time and i just enjoy it more so if i
can go solar
have better weapon damage and then just
you know annoy the stasis people cool
but mine's mostly like if i'm using
solar ability then i switch to a weapon
i've got a damage bonus
right that sounds that sounds fun for me
depending on
again like how like difficult to lock
down with stasis there's very few places
in pve that's going to do a damn thing
but to mess with people in pvp not bad
the one that i'm worried about
is starring your scales the hunter one
now granted you said there are powerful
hunter exotics for sure
there are a ton of them but my question
would be like if hunters
you know somebody goes a full intellect
build and can get
they're super started and you have say
three hunters
in a party saying trials and they can
start chaining like you know waiting on
their
supers and stuff like if they start
chaining supers and the orbs help each
other get it more quickly
and it's more powerful and then more of
them have it more frequently
i could see like bigger groups of
hunters in a pvp setting if they're
sharing orbs
start steamrolling other teams i don't
know how much it could get there but if
they can really get that orb sharing
going as a team
it could be something you could really
troll people like six person team of
hunters with this in iron banner
just like rolling rolling around the map
so i don't know how much it's going to
help you know you'll know how you feel
about that i don't know how it feels
like it may it's like it may not be that
powerful and believe me the warlock one
for me is like
pve pvp just all the time just well the
thing that recently um
knew her out of my chat he was showing
me a chaperone
sitting in like luna faction so it's got
the empowering range
hit that thing from like 25 meters with
chaperone and i was like gee
what so if you could make that mobile
and then just
if you could just send that out and
somebody's now my shotgun hits this far
and i move
like that's terrifying extremely short
it can't be that long but like that
could be
it could be like i just like the ideas
like i can actually see some fun for all
three some of these i'm like
hey the hunter throwing knife bounces
two times or something like that one
didn't do it for me but at least all of
these i'm happy to see like
i could see use for all of these and i
think that's probably the first time in
a while i've been like
yep i give all these at least a decent
chance all of them
y'all excited be excited because you
know i'm so
used to mentally as a warlock having to
be
a solar warlock just to be into that
whole support role
so now i'm like oh well now yeah you
gotta give me excitement like that i
could be avoid like a devour locked
help myself and also lay rips down and
do stuff like
it opens it up for the other two to be
have some support capability
i'm excited about that y'all should've
told me that even
like perfect example i know the disabled
right now even when stasis hurt
you have that out and you still have
your rift up and
you're still helping out and you're
breathing things so it's just like
yeah yeah i'm thinking about souls too
yeah these boots gonna get some run
because don't believe warlock booster
trash but these ones
are you forgetting geomags no geos is
good
geo's like tip to scale you know but you
know
i take it back the one that always
pisses me off and i'm demanding a rework
bungie
prometheus spur we gotta talk about
prometheus bird that was a waste that
was a waste of time
i don't see any functionality for that
and we need to rework for free because
they look hot but i'm like i'm not using
this thing
like it was weird for me i felt like
those boots are made for like a horde
mode or something
yeah like you get your super back a lot
so you kill stuff and you just
make a bunch of like risks for your
teammates so you guys are just shredding
stuff
it's like seriously like it reminds me
like a horrible like
we need to kill a bunch of stuff and be
efficient throughout the whole thing
how do we grips up you know like that
that's what it reminds me of but i don't
really see
a spot for it like i know like i mean it
with my clan mates and like
we made it work but like it's not really
yeah it's not a real exotic yeah those
actually did look pretty cool i remember
those
looking to you um outside of the
legendaries
outside of those we have the sidearm
stasis shooting steinhardt i know you're
excited about this e
stasis doesn't bother me in pvp honestly
i'm not one of those mostly because i
don't pvp that much
and if i do i'm like there are moments
where i'm like in my fire super and i
get frozen i'm like this feels wrong
but i don't pvp enough that i'm like
that it ruins my day all the time
but it is funny people like hey can you
please take sixes out of pvp which by
the way it's not gonna happen it's in
the game
that's just not going anywhere but on
the other side
now they gave you a gun that shoots it
for the first time
and it's not a little grenade launcher
it's a now i don't know if it takes like
a critical kill
or if you got to proc it up with a
certain number of shots because he's
shooting goblins beforehand
reload spins it up and fires
i don't know ek thoughts on this i can't
i can't decide if it's one that's
actually got a lot of potential or not
the gun is very balanced how they did it
right because there's a
first of all there's no stasis shield in
the game so it's in
they put in a kinetic slot and you gotta
you gotta kill someone in order to proc
it
so like a chill clip or something like
that so you have to kill someone
and then when you're proclaiming you
have to hold down and then charges
almost like uh
what are like those reload animations
for like other guns
when you're switching stuff but my thing
is i believe it's like
slow then like freeze and shatter
something like that
yeah so you might like we saw the guy
kill a bunch of things and then reload
and crucible i don't think anybody's
gonna be killing like
oh let me kill you with the sidearm
you know most people have a 120 that can
take you out from really far
or a pulse rifle let me kill you real
quick like up close
and let me reload and go freeze this guy
i feel like for all that
i could just run you know my abilities i
just throw two kunais
i can throw a grenade you know like i if
i'm a warlock i could throw my melody to
freeze you i could put up a rift to
freeze you
so like i feel like it was balanced out
because i'm gonna be honest i'm not
going to crucify no damn sidearm
i was like the only one i know might be
true vanguard and more power to him he
might have fun with it he's the only one
who knows like really repping sidearms
but
yeah i think it might be a youtube video
but like
yeah i don't know i don't think it's a
big deal yeah
listen but if the norm was shooting
stasis right off the bat
obviously if like if you know if it was
just like
freeze sag all the damn promise people
that is what it would be
you're right yeah no no
no i'm out you don't want to shoot it
sub-zero in the chat oh yeah look man
i'll hear you i do i do feel the kill
part of it is balance you know what i
mean
i'm curious to see what archetype
because if it falls into
um what's that trying to like it's a um
omalon
energy side i'm actually team sidearm
sometimes
on crucible i'll be getting like usually
i do my little back up
against the apes when the apes come i
just little back pedal like
and get them out of it but um i'm
curious it's in a kinetic spot
you know it's probably going to be for
all accounts a a better pve weapon you
know what i'm saying
and i'm just curious to see how that
would be
a question when it does the freeze did
it's a single target freeze or can you
it looks like a bullet i mean there's
not a lot there's only one guy in front
of him
but he does tend to hit him about center
mass so he's like it doesn't look like a
camera i'm not freezing like five people
no
what i can get away with nah nah
i asked i asked a lot of questions about
that damn gun i was like
cool it's gonna be like one of those
guns that you just pick up you have fun
with
maybe but yeah yeah it's not gonna break
the sandbox thank god
okay good man i'm curious that's all
we'll see how it happens but uh
your thoughts uh i mean i think i think
ek pretty well said it i think it's the
fact that you need to do something to
proc it first
yeah without being just like straight
out of the gate whether it's criticals
whether it's kills whatever the specific
qualification is
once you hit that there are certain
people who are definitely going to be
like all right i'm just going to run
sidearms today
and i'm going to troll people with the
shoot the freezy bullet but outside of
that like
it's going to be some clips and some fun
i don't imagine it's going to be game
changing
because you got to be in a pretty close
engagement for sidearms to do its thing
and if it's like a trial situation
you're not going to have it procked
already
yeah like there's going to be one clip
somewhere where somebody's like ping
ping ping ping ping ping with a sidearm
and they freeze the last guy
juke on him and then get to like finish
him up but that's about it there's gonna
be one clip out there where somebody
gets like a three team wipe with a
sidearm with this gun
and the final freezing bolt they just
shut him down laugh at him and then kill
him
one time i don't i don't see it
happening again so yeah yeah
yeah it would probably be like yoden
like when joseph first came up
like oh my god i'm you know this thing
tracks and it hits me
now like you see someone with the charge
you just move
and then you don't get hit right like
someone sees someone using that side i'm
like oh i'm not dying to this you know
like
you know what i mean or oh he just
killed someone with the sidearm on the
feet let me back up real quick
you know because i think about this way
too when you charge up that shot
it's not going to last that damn long
it's probably going to be like kill clip
you know like
it only lasts for like three for four
seconds so like
if you don't use it it's gone again and
you gotta try to get another kill so
oh so you think it's gonna operate like
almost like a desperado in a sense like
you've got a
quick amount of seconds to do it and
then yeah yeah
okay yeah i don't think that i don't
think that thing is going to stack
gotcha though
it's gonna be interesting yeah cryo visa
i want to use it now just for just a
troll just to see what
all right on a separate note let people
sit on their frozen rounds yeah
well i killed a few people i'm just
gonna like hold this in i was like
yeah i was like yeah if you can sit
there and just reload and it's just
sitting there like but if it works like
say like a memento mori where it's just
there first bullet
and they've got they've got
functionality where it could but yeah
that would definitely
that was like but again that would be
stupid as well
so it's like you just sit there with it
be like
all right who's coming
yeah like what happened i don't know i
blacked out i was frozen like that's
what
yeah this is funny okay can we talk
about this armor
both the fallen season armor and then
the ornaments
the titan helmets can we please talk
about these like
big ass dome one looks like a fallen
shank and i can't get on board with
either of these titan helmets like
i gotta get you with that okay i got
warlock predator warlock green goblin i
got some like
fallen eyes and cool like feathers and
then i got
big old squished like somebody shoved a
shank on top of the titan i can't do it
like
do you guys like some of the armor nah
from the previous seasons most of the
armor has been like ridiculous
i don't know yeah i can't get jiggy with
this there's this
i've always people are people rocking
though man
that that hot dog looking helmet that
the titan got this season
i can't rock that no that's not the hot
dog helmet that's the hitachi helmet
yeah whatever that is people rock me i'm
ugly as possible people still worry i'm
like this is some bull what is up with
like the giant triple bar
thing on the titans back as well what is
why why is that it's like i'm taking
a flagpole out somewhere that it's a
collapsible flagpole and it's stuck i
don't understand like some of those
at least there's no goofy stuff like
that but the titan helms they're just
like
they're oddly wide and squished
you guys have like cool eyes and green
goblin and the seasonal ornaments i've
got a pink night rider mouth sitting on
a heavy shank like
i am i i don't know like i like the
aesthetic of basically everything from
the head down
i think they actually did cool there
with the fallen with more of the
drapery and like the clothing and kind
of like the fur look
and then i like kind of the tron neon of
the ornaments but man my helmets just
ruined both
i'll have to put another helmet on i can
get on board with the rest yo
hunt has been eaten like at least they
join us at least passable
but i just can't it's a warlock i cannot
get down with this right here
i'm i'm i'm getting the everest armor
anyway yeah
everybody tests going but we gonna be
eating that test
picking up some stuff i mean 30 30 per
character that's
that's like five different looks right
there because of an exotic put on too
yeah you know and then they're
they're fixing the uh the solstice gear
because they said that in twab
so like people that got like the old
social stuff because i know a lot of
people are mad
yeah like we don't get to like you know
uh
put this in for transmog so i'm glad
they worked on that
but i swear there were some people like
i should have all my gear be transmitted
i was like
that's like 4 000 pieces of gear
and how much memory that is like that's
a lot
you know what yeah you you fight for
that can i have more of all space yeah
oh yeah get this man give this man a
thousand
where you want to look okay i want false
face
i'm function over fashion i'm with you i
will yeah you know like everybody's
gone now we're getting a bunch of
seasons so that vault got to open up
because now there's more weapons going
into it you know
that's the argument right there you know
yeah sun setting gone and now more
armor is like oh you don't need to keep
that i need every option of weapon
because you never know what they're good
18 months later we get a buff on rocket
launchers be like oh those are good now
well i deleted some good ones i didn't
have to if i had yeah believe me i'm
with you on the vault space because i
live
perpetually in hell with that one
um fusion rifle the what is it called
null composure i actually really like
the
coloring on this one like the blue
undertones of the black and the yellow
it doesn't even hardly look like a
fusion rifle but i was like it looks
cool so that looks like it's going to be
the pursuit weapon give me that loaded
question vibe that i like that's the
that's the one they might be throwing
that perk on again
i love that fusion loaded question was
fun yeah so we got that one
a lot of people were talking about that
like i need to get that perk back i need
to get that perk back i was like
man i don't know what's going on this
gun we'll see
because it was different you know it was
fun
so yeah we got some uh
subclass tuning for stasis looks like
hunter's the freeze detonation
again yeah that one's getting nerfed and
then you can actually see the red ring
that i like
i like like because i feel like i've
like leaned out of the way and it's like
not quite enough to like go around the
tornado of doom um titans nothing too
major warlocks obviously the
bleak watcher aspect now grants two
fragment slots i think it was one before
so somebody said that
above yeah uh the chaos reaches not
gonna have like
ridiculous through-wall splash damage
situation so that's gonna get fixed
um the nav mode the new like ghost
bounty scrolling and everything like
that do you guys think that's
do you think it's ever going to get
overburdened like depending on if your
bounding slots are too full you guys
think that'll probably be just mostly a
good thing
which date okay uh
right now i i keep thinking about this
i'm like there's gonna be a whole lot of
crap on the screen that you're gonna try
to scroll through
i i don't know i don't know if i'm gonna
be a huge fan of that
we'll see yeah because like we already
have like a screen for it that we could
just go into
and kind of look at it like our bounties
and stuff like that now we pull out our
ghost so we can see it
hmm one of my friends is jumping for joy
for this he thinks this is one of the
greatest quality of life so i'm like
okay you know
god bless celeste well yeah but it is
what it is but you know look i'm always
i'm never going to be against ui you
know stuff but
you know it is that's a lot it's like
because what is it now like okay
all the bounties right every bounty look
like all the bounties and quests and all
that stuff is going to be
like 30 bounties i'm like there's no way
in hell i'm scrolling through those
it seems a bit excessive to have them
all so
yeah i mean like it's nice with people
that are probably like in lost sectors
like yeah i need to get my light up
but no like no i got like five bounties
if i want to see them i could just go
back into my thing
oh look that's what i got you know yeah
they might be their own though yep some
people don't like that
oh shout out to boys she said did ek
tell you how tall he is i'm tall and i
feel small next to ethan
this man is six five i had my best
friend for
years six five i've i'm about six foot
and i feel
short in life until i start meeting
other people so no this man
six five so what did you what uh would
you play in basketball
uh i was i was like a guard forward
it was like in between basically yeah no
no you already know so we got the what
else we got you know sandbox stuff
uh working through it yeah so
yeah we got the subclass stuff basically
kevin yana sees the sandbox discipline
lead covers pvp set a quick list of some
places they're actively looking at for
future um
stasis freeze kind of how that works the
slow accuracy penalties and i've heard a
lot of the pvp guys talk about that
whisper of hedrons what is that does
anybody know what that one does
specifically
i think i have extra damage oh
so they're working on some stuff for a
pvp patch coming
uh you got the ui changes obviously now
this is where i wondered like
how much story was going to tie into
vault of glass because
they said legends that's all they call
it add it to the
director destinations tab and this is
where you'll find vault of glass in just
a few weeks and that's where i wondered
if there is any time to the story if
like is destiny content vaults just
being like hey here's this old stuff you
can play again it looks better
this is in the you know legends go
art like almost feels like an archive
right so i couldn't tell how to read
that word
to know if there is going to be story
stuff or it's just like hey the old
reigns back go have fun
and that's it that's why like my theory
before seems to may have been shot by me
reading that one sentence
yeah i always got the vibe it was gonna
be like a separate entity just like an
old school playlist
nothing narratively connected it would
be cool if they did it but
i've always got the vibe that this is
something they're gonna do and kind of
like
bring back old content without
necessarily a narrative tie-in so
was it yeah i don't know i always
thought um
that rage shouldn't be tied to like the
plans anyway they should just have like
a section where you click on raids
because at the end of destiny 1 we had
it
was the age of trines or whatever yeah
click on it you had all the rays in the
same menu
it would be nice to have all the raids
like that so then like
you know some of the raids that they
took away they could probably bring it
back because it's not tied to the planet
anymore it's just as much
it's own space you know preach it
brother
featured raid perhaps weekly featured
raid would be nice
that would be nice yeah i think they
were talking about them something like
that
okay okay yeah i was like that would i
just feel like a weekly featured raid
weekly featured dungeon give us a reason
to be like hey the pinnacle is not just
prophecy for
the umpteenth you know month in a row be
like hey if you want to go run
a bit of heresy you can go get a
pinnacle in there this we can be like oh
that'd be kind of fun to go mix it up a
little like those
the content's sitting there and i feel
like that's just sometimes i feel it
could be nice to give that a little
refresher
agree especially if they if they can if
they add one more dungeon i feel like
that'll be time
yeah because then you'll have four you
got four raids at that point so
some variety would be good in there uh
they also said they're moving the helm
to the director
so you know basically just quality of
life and also if you focus in umbral you
get what comes out of it you don't have
to walk around the corner and
then decrypt it just little quality of
life stuff is coming
they did say glory valor and infamy uh
they've got some changes coming for
those and this is
what is planned for season 15 which we
still don't know what it is
um or we know when it is now basically
because that's when vanguard reputation
is going to come they're going to
rebalance infamy more in line with valor
that stuff's going to come with 15
but they're kind of basically making
more of glory infamy
valor this next season a bit more linear
a little more straightforward to deal
with so we got some stuff there
we got the eververse archive and we have
trace rifle mods
yeah it's been that long to get trace
rifle bots
interesting is there any i was like
honestly i mostly just see people
putting divinity and reserves on
probably for that one more than just
about anything else
depending on uptick for sure yeah are
there any other trace rifles that you
guys like would like to pull out of the
vault to use with stuff like this or is
there if they
not really still doing it lens is pretty
nice because you can just keep killing
and like
keeps refilling as well so if you had if
you were running two special ammo
weapons
only special will drop so you just keep
having ammo for that thing too
you probably run like a sniper and that
right because it's a special ammo
um kohar is not bad cohort used to do a
lot of damage
i don't know i don't know if they fixed
it though um
because you weren't able to stack the
damage with like divinity bubbles or
anything like that like
none of the the the other rifles were
working with divinity
right i think they fixed that in the
previous match i don't remember
but it'd be nice to kind of see those
two like put together again
because you know cohort the long like
the the longer you hold it the more
damage it did
yeah it would be pretty neat to see that
ramp up like a divinity bubble or
something
yeah that'd be fine yeah i remember it
was the move back in leviathan however
that was like
oh yeah i think that one point yeah
but it's good to see them do that well
there's a little bit of pvp you get
momentum control and
team scorched coming back wow
[Laughter]
oh joy the commitment to pvp
yeah yeah this is this is what i'm
waiting for that momentum control
i got me hype no map though
[Laughter]
yeah pvp man what are we doing out here
man what are we doing out here
it's crazy you know i'm tired to talk
about it
it's like beating the dead drum i i
would like just some clarity on when
they
plan on addressing it that's all just
let me know when's the timetable
that they are actually going to
seriously address it because
it's it's the butt of a joke we the
forgotten children man like
we the black sheep out here man no no
love for pvp i just
what's the love man that's it i was like
have you seen the trials loot this
weekend
yeah i mean that that's definitely nice
there's incentive to get in there
hammer igneous hammer igneous hammer and
adapting samurai's like are you
serious well they know they cuz no one i
mean
i shouldn't say that i don't know the
population that was but it's been proven
that when they put a good weapon in
there yet it's going to get
engagement but it's just like bro we've
got to do something this is
this is really a joke now and you know
between that and the transmog
i just need a state of bungie eventually
when is it happening that's all once you
communicate
i'm cool i'll lay off you what i don't
know then i'm gonna be in my feelings
and i gotta i gotta get out at work
so that's just where i'm at with it you
know what i'm saying but um hold on
i said he said you laugh but you'll be
happy it's back what's that side on
catalyst question
we'll see we'll see it's just again i'm
just tired of the neglection
and acting like it doesn't exist when
pve and other votes get
a lot of love so he came i was like i
know you do
tons of pve stuff obviously gm's are
kind of your jam and stuff like that
what are your like what
does pvp appeal that much to you is
there anything you'd like to see
in there are you waiting for just like a
big change to kind of jump back in do
you pvp that much in the first place
bro i mean i used to pvp a lot i don't
know anymore
uh pp is in a weird place and even like
with trials
i don't even think like bungie yourself
can fix that because
the thing is even if there's low
incentive
people still like the the population
goes up but it's not what it used to be
i think
trials was like this like prize thing
that we had in dusty one
and not too many people were like new to
that especially
when we moved to pc where a lot more
players got like a lot better
but the the thing that like hurts the
most
is the population man if you think about
it because if there were like
a million people playing right and
there's like
a thousand cheaters you wouldn't see it
as much right because i think every game
on pcs shooters is always like some
crazy [ __ ]
but the thing is there's like maybe 15
000 people playing
and there's like a thousand cheaters
every other match is a freaking cheater
which sucks
um and i know they say they you know
they're working on entity and stuff like
that they can't tell us
yeah i just honestly to me i feel like
that needs to get like re-scrapped and
like find a way
to like change the game mode to make it
to where people want to play it
right not just rewarding but like some
of that people enjoy like
perfect example you get into a match
right now if you face in like three
people running uh chaos
they're just gonna wait it out there's
no time incentive to move
there's not like there's nothing that
tells someone like oh i need to do
something
right there's no objective maybe like
the the time on the rounds maybe needs
to be a little bit shorter
or something yeah have you ever noticed
like
there's times where i run trials card
and i'm like yo why does this car feel
like it's been an
hour because like the other teams were
like playing slow now you gotta
now you gotta wait for the base to the
grabbing it's just like good point
that's a good point you know and then
sometimes the weapons that are like
metal or that that have been made for
the game mode
are just they're not the greatest like
you know like people don't want to use
some of those things because then
it slows down the whole entire gameplay
you know
it's like when i look back at like
destiny one crucible i loved it
and when i look at destiny 2's crucial
i'm like
like the thing the destiny more you
didn't have to be the greatest player
bro you
go in there you just have fun man like
you didn't have to be like top one
percent or like
even three percent to go flawless you
can play with your friends
get drunk or whatever and possibly go
flawless
now it's like twist i gotta like sweat
my butt off
like every corner like yo he's doing
this oh he might be cheating you put
your sword in there
you know but now when i get into people
my brain just turns off i'm just like
shooting if i die i die just
like i don't care about as much anymore
and i'll tell my friends this too like
if you want to like make something
content and you're trying to grow as a
baby player
i feel like the new apex arena is one of
those things
that kind of works out because that's
the crucible for me was always fun
right it wasn't like i wasn't trying to
be a competitive player
like we had so many fun guns to just go
in the sandbox and work with
if you think about it in destiny one we
had so many broken things blink shotties
we had hammers bro we had like some of
the craziest things bro
and it was still fun like i remember
when no backup plan
and universal remote was a thing you
know what i'm saying but we still played
it it wasn't like
bad like people freaking enjoyed it
people made clips man
now is i don't know anymore you know
and we don't we don't get we don't get
charged for content when it comes to
crucify they're like
i i have a lot of friends that like
banjo what's going on crucible is there
new maps i'm like
they're not charging us for anything
they're not even charging us for end
game crucible which is trials
right even that doesn't have a paywall
even that is free
and it's weird to me you know because
then if we're not paying for it
like if we ask about it they're not
really going to say much you know
i spoke my piece about it too at some
people like it's weird
to have something that's like part of
the game right
yet like like you said we got a new like
trailer
there was nothing shown about a crucible
one like
it's almost like the baby that's there
but at the same time like
it gets like messed with like here and
there or gets a little tuning
but it's not like the main thing is i
don't know i don't know it's just
perfectly you said it perfectly it's
neglect but it's
it it's it's not acknowledging it and
it's just an
interesting shift as to why why you know
again is it a resource thing whatever it
is but it's like you said it's trailer
after trailer season after season
you know and you just don't see anything
about it and the most we'll get
is when it's time for sandbox you'll say
okay we're gonna tune this we're gonna
tune that
stasis here with this weapon there you
know they'll do that
but when it comes to actual modes when
it comes to actual
incentive and really taking the time to
really revamp and flush it out and say
hey we notice you guys are not playing
you know this is a focus of ours we want
to do x y and z
it's not there and it's just very
curious as to why i
don't know and then why they don't want
to talk about it that's the other thing
so
yeah you know just enough season pvp
i was like i mean i'm with you guys
because at this point i'm not a hardcore
pvp person i'll jump in occasionally do
some bounties do some seasonal stuff
whatever's in there
you know play a couple different modes
you know maybe get carried a little bit
in trials get a weapon or two something
like not often
anything crazy hardcore but i'm with you
guys the main
reason is like there's not much
incentive for me to do that there's not
much
variety in there i mean even just take
iron banner it's a general activity
yeah but i mean it's like we joked
before it's like you can't
put rift in there one one time just
every so often be like hey you want to
play rift it's going to be this week
people may be like oh we want control
but like once a season when you've got
four of them on the calendar or
something like that you can't get a
little
just little stuff like that it just does
and i think the silence is deafening to
a point
where rumors about the other ip
no i was like that's i mean is that
is that the question of where the pvp
focus is at is that to the point where
they're like
we could work on putting rift into
destiny or
we can save all of these pvp things and
go put them in this other thing is that
the more you think about it the more
you're like is that where it's all going
because it does seem at this point
sandbox balancing is a thing but no maps
in like two years no modes that people
have asking for for a while
crucible labs has faded away there's not
a whole lot of
yeah like crucible labs have been a
while
and maps were just there's no like at
this point it is witch queen where
you're like are we gonna get it if you
don't see anything in which queen you're
like
all right i gotta know something they
have to say something before then
because if if
like which queen is the point where i
don't know
i mean it'll be there but that's like it
is odd though as very
pvp pve like person pvp is the stuff
that keeps it alive on the weekends
the reason destiny has twitch on weekend
viewing mostly at all
is trials is pvp is stuff like that and
then there's the people like ek who are
doing like carries and sherpas and
things but it's like a chunk of it is
pvp
especially on the weekends and they're
trying with trials but they are not
helping their case
so it's very strange to know to know
about the ip being a rumor
like the job description and otherwise
and it could be a couple years away but
as you said
they they've got to say something let's
just say because the longer it goes the
worse it's going to get
the worse it's going to get yeah
absolutely i agree
this is the weird thing about shows like
this like ek it's like we were on it's
like
i could go through and be like we have a
whole new set of seasonal content to
cover
and we've gone on shows that have gone
like far past two hours
not even at two right now and i'm like
are we actually at the end of the show
we actually went through like we're
we're oddly efficient when we have a lot
to cover and then we're horribly
inefficient
yeah when we have like random tangents
talk 30 minutes about food in the middle
of it like
random stuff happens but like we got to
go we got to be on schedule boom okay go
like um
but i wanted to ask one more thing for
you guys and this is kind of what we'll
wrap it up
we finally know the length of this
coming season it's three and a half
months so we finally actually got a date
on the schedule it's going to go through
august 24th
that leaves september october november
december
and we know which queen is coming
sometime in 2022
maybe it's january that's five months
maybe it's february it's six months
depending on how long they need
how would you guys like season 15 to be
handled
and if i don't give you an option you
can always use option c if you come up
with one
do they do a five six month season and
try and date it
and give us like you know kind of your
front loaded season like they did this
time and your iron banners and your
trials
and somehow eventually connect it or
they just do a three-month season
and then say okay now we're gonna you
know dig deep and work on which queen
we'll get it to you when we can
what would you like to see what do you
expect to see or if there's an option c
i didn't think of
that too ek
guess gets to go first on this stuff
well
i mean i don't know i feel like we might
get another season and then
who knows we might get which queen early
we might get a late or they might deal
with it did
uh with the previous season where they
extended another two months
um you gotta remember too i think cross
play is coming in during that time
and you know if if they bring back
another raid
and they at a new rate i think that'll
be more enough for us to kind of keep
busy during that time
um my focus though is like
the transition of everything right pv
pvp
lore all of it if they if they have it
because the thing is they're good at
scheduling stuff and kind of like
putting stuff up on the calendar so it
seems to me like they'll probably have
something set up for us to do during
that time
i don't know about like a two month of
just like seeing nothing
yeah yeah that's that's the part yes
we're coming to worst we might get like
two seasons
like of like three and three meeting
like as late as going into 2022
and then maybe february is when witch
queen starts you know i mean
yeah right more like we might just end
up getting two seasons
and then that i'm not sure because when
we're looking at the past i think
there's one more season after the next
so then they might just suspend that one
and find
ways to do it because what during the
holidays christmas we have the
that seasonal dawning yeah dawning as
well so
you you know you never know they might
be able to pull something off
i just i hope that they have something
you know for us to do yeah that that's
my biggest sake
usually yeah i mean good point it is an
interesting situation because we know
the length of the season and we know
when which queen is actually going to
start right so
it's how they handle the buffer right
because one would be
it would be kind of wild to be like all
right that's it see you today
see you next season nothing more y'all
you know that would be hilarious i doubt
that happens but it is interesting
do you know how many we get packed in
between and if it's like
you know two shorter ones or i'm curious
this is this is unique territory because
generally you know that big fall
expansion is always that september
you know lately maybe october later
month but we've never had it where it's
like yo
we're not getting the big expansion
until next year which is with witch
queen
so this is an interesting position and
i'm curious
i'm curious yeah i'm dying to know how
you want to handle e because i know this
is a big thing for you you know
i mean i've listed multiple options of
how it could go
you've got you could make it a normal
season
three three and a half months something
like that the reason i would worry
sometimes people really complain about
the drip feed right so if you try and
stretch
like a story over five months or you're
like front load a season for seven weeks
and then like at the end of the season
you've got
a tie into witch queen right there's a
big gap in the middle
there's your trials your iron banners if
they have maybe a mission or something
that you can do
and at some point there's going to be a
lot of games coming out in the fall and
there's going to be some okay downtime
and i'm okay with that and that's why
part of me is like however there's
probably going to be down time i'm fine
with it
my biggest thing is like i wonder if
they'll even date
witch queen when season 15 starts
right like are they even going to tell
us the length of that in the first place
so they're gonna be like
here's the dates and more question to
which like an arrow to witch queen like
is it even gonna be a specific enough to
know you know epilogue this time that's
a weird thing by the way on the end of
this season calendar
they've never said that like epilogue
that's like the anecdote
at the end of the story i'm like what
happens at the end of this story
so i'm very hopefully it's more than the
guardian games closing ceremony that's
all i gotta say because there was
nothing there
but for me it's just very
i want them to take all the time they
need to make which queen
what it hopefully can be all right let
me let me double back so are you
comfortable
with them taking a break i am 100
comfortable yeah absolutely there's
there's going to be there is eventually
going to be some holiday games
right there's going to be some light
months but somehow may is full of five
of them
like you got returnal you got resident
evil you got biomutant and then
two others at least i'm like that's one
month and then of course things are
going to be planned for holiday there's
stuff we haven't seen
um you know you've got your horizons
you've got your halos
whether both of or either of those make
it there's tons of stuff in the holidays
there oh wait that's like
that is a time for sales so what
happened he's also working on something
no no we'll see yeah
so like for me the gap is fine
because at some point there's going to
be a break my curiosity is
if they're willing to do that if they're
willing to say hey iron banner
could go like every couple of weeks you
know pop that one up to give people
pinnacles to
grind for give you extra time to work on
all the previous seasons of stuff in
case you jump in late
trials is there every weekend and then
you know you can work on what you want
to but it's like at some point i feel
like they do have to be like
we want to focus on this we can't get
cheese pepper and little stuff in
because i'd rather have a solid season
15 that they like are happy with the
quality of
as opposed to trying like jam little
fillers in here
just just for time so i was like yeah i
was like well
it could be five months and that's a
long season but i'm okay with the
downtime because
it's on it's a bit nice to have the
brakes like ek's playing genshin and
stuff like that so it's like it's been
good to
step away because then when you fire a
destiny gun again you're like that that
feels it feels good as opposed to living
it every day
so man yeah i've been telling people
that all the time like
if you you know if you feel burnt out or
you're mad
or like the thing is like the video game
is supposed to like
get your spirits up and keep you like
happy and share up if you're mad playing
a video game
stop playing and go outside check it out
stop
lose something else go for a walk real
quick
that's the wrong thing you know like
sure you're mad
someone teabagged you or something like
that cool you know like
that i i still don't get it how virtual
nuts like
but like you know if that happens you
know just like
step outside real quick because like
you're playing video games to enjoy them
you're not playing video games to get
frustrated and be like this person
should be fired and all that no you're
playing it because you're like
i want to enjoy it you're not going to
watch a tv show that you're not going to
like
no you're going to watch a show that
you're interested in
right because you want to see what's
going to happen um and that's the same
thing with video games like i try to
tell people like
look if you're not happy right you know
just
take like a day or two off go do
something else because for me like when
i play the games and i get back to
destiny i'm like man this game is like
it's just fun like i'm like there's no
game that feels like this
at all you know like you going nessa so
you're just spamming around
like the game is very beautiful man like
well designed
you know absolutely so it's one of those
things like you might need to you know
step away a little bit and then you come
back and you can enjoy it more
yeah i have friends like up away and
then come back and like man i still hate
crucible i'm like
it happens right
now you're right they come back like man
a lot of these guys are boss i'm killing
everybody i'm like look look see
you happy right no you never know man
you never know
i agree man you gotta take a step back
you know
recharge your batteries and even when i
was playing outright for a while you
know and then obviously i have my issue
without writers that i just
solved myself people who i saw myself
but um anyway um now all jokes aside but
you know
it was good to log back in because i was
like you know what let me get
the air apparent catalyst and yeah i'm
trying to like i know machine gun's
about to get the ball
you know what i mean so i'm trying to
get in that have everything ready
for the new meta before it shifts and i
ain't gonna lie
i got that count i was like yo this
little tanky as hell with this thing
like
you know when you rev it up you got the
next year and then it was one of those
things i'm like damn i still
nothing plays like this it still feels
good it still looks good
you know what kind of thing and the last
play okay you said that i completely
agree
that they could leverage is
cross play for the full yeah that is big
so if they if they like i said even if
the season is weak
you know you can put that in and be like
look all guardians together you know
what i mean that's a big deal i mean
that'll
playlists that'll build basically any
streamer content creator at this point
could just be like
i mean the way i just did it here's the
join code and you could help anybody on
any platform
yeah sherpas and stuff like that anybody
in my streams like i don't play
with that many because i'm on pc and
there's a lot of console people
so generally it's like if they finally
want to come in the game and especially
if it's pv
i'm not going to care like what console
they're on per se if i'm on pc i might
know if they have an og ps4 xbox one
because those load times are going to be
slow you learn that one on
crossplay but other than that oh yeah i
learned that i writers
like i was like man what the hell is
going on what are you doing it's like
nvme who don't got the mvp like i'm
pretty sure my nvme
just could have built another hard drive
for you by now come on
it's like i'm i'm with you guys like i
want them to take the time
because they've mentioned what what i've
always mentioned
armor i want to mean more and they
mentioned they do want to make armor
more than just like an annual stat
replacement i'm like cool an armor 3.0
that's like that's an exciting piece
take the time you need to make that all
you want
same thing with the witch queen you're
bringing sabathune this is like outside
of oryx who you built up with crota
this is somebody in the lore that people
if they're paying attention have been
hearing about
four years yeah i swear to god if she's
a strike boss i'm going to kill somebody
like
that may not be a goal situation yeah so
it's like they need to do
witch queen right to kick off the final
three years trilogy whatever they're
calling for the light and dark saga
so i want them to take the time and not
rush anything
take the time to qa extra stuff because
beyond like came out a little funky
same stuff so it's like i'm okay with
the time i'm just kind of curious how
they're gonna balance it
so it's like as we because i was
wondering if this season might be
five months or so to like extend that
one a little more so the next one was a
little closer to that hopeful date
it could be six months and that's just
going to be a weird timing to see
so i'm just i was kind of curious if
your guys takes on that one but
um as for timing wise we are about to
hit the nail
literally on the head for our guest over
here um he's been streaming early i was
up early and he's sitting there
streaming already i was like
man dude you've been going like i get up
early to go to work sometimes like at 4
30 in the morning but i was like man i
tuned in your stream at like five you'll
be jamming already snow yeah he was
rocking
he's he's an early riser right now out
there on the west coast so it goes nice
um but yeah at this point i don't have
much else left anything else you guys
want to
cover that i may miss for upcoming stuff
no i'm a hype man nice little trailer
you know
excited getting ready to jump back in
again you know see what's going on and
back back to the life again you know we
do
the new aspect it looks like the new
aspect of stasis
you know what's crazy about beyond light
we're still getting stuff from beyond
light because we're still getting access
to everything
but uh i don't know if they're tying
through the grenade they look like the
warlock through a grenade
right yeah the speed and the protein yes
yeah and then after the things that were
frozen got killed it dropped the spear
and then the spear anybody could pick up
because i saw the titan pick it up but
i'm pretty sure the warlock threw that
grenade yes so
we'll see how that goes you know that's
you can pick up experience are like
throwing out things in game that should
be fun too you know
because they already have the mechanics
from uh
like the war mine type spear they
already have yeah yeah yeah
so they have like that concept built
they just frostify it basically so
yeah that that's one of those even
things like i mentioned it in the
trailer and shout out the screenshot and
i'm like
yep smooth forgot about that so yeah
there's there's a lot to look forward to
for this one
narrative team has been absolutely
killing it so i mean where they take the
story good to see aikora back
yeah and again a different if a
different voice actor brings her back
into the story more often more power to
it because
she's always got some powerful moments
when she just blows up a ship with a
nova bomb in the start of destiny 2 and
you're like damn she's got some
she's got some anger issues but that's
totally fine uh
for me the big you know science family i
love the fact that they can kind of
interact again
and yeah reaching out to myth rags so
now we you know we're not cut off from
her
i like she's a vanguard like she has to
be involved so
definitely like that seeing her again
well that's about all i got uh before we
go
um ek outside of please go follow this
man
um yes follow him everywhere he's a
quality
dude but if you jump in his chat you'll
be nothing but like chill vibes
you are like one of the calm you'll be
in the middle of a grand master like
checking out
chat answering a question you are
the master of chill so it's like and
it's a good thing so if people want a
peaceful
got some always good music like any time
i popped in
like doesn't matter what it is i'm just
always sitting here just like always
bopping into the beat
i was like yeah let's go oh man that's
the only man i will say like i work at a
are we gonna studio and sometimes we'll
record our classes and post them to our
facebook groups they are private groups
michael jackson is the fastest one to
get muted so it's like
because i saw the algorithm is like it's
a michael jackson song we know it
so you may hear it but you're not going
to hear it later but yeah always good
music but i want to say
whatever you got coming up anything cool
to announce anything fun
where they can find it what you what
you're going to be doing next season
pretty much the floor is yours for
whatever you would like to say to
anybody who hears this
uh well i don't think i have anything
crazy coming up but uh
like i said i'm like when it comes to
seasons i'm not like
crazy excited but i'm always looking
forward to something new um
so we'll see what we're going to be
diving into
um i do hope at some point in the future
because i think they were talking about
like more darkness subclasses yes i do
hope at some point
that like they go back into the light
subclasses and figure that out
like perfect example for me right i was
hoping like
stasis how is set up is so nice right
with fragments that could do different
things
and then you have like the slow the
freeze and the shattered thing
imagine like maybe with like solar
you can like uh you can basically
burn and then maybe or like heat and
burn
and then like what was it like i writers
has a pyro thing or whatever yeah
yeah you might be able to just like
scorch after right like imagine
something like that
and the subclasses that we have already
set up as fragments in that class
i want to see stuff like that in destiny
so like i'm hoping to see more stuff
like
that and besides that i've i just been
i've been chilling man just working on
my health so my schedule has changed a
bit so i do get up a lot earlier because
my body's like
i'm not used to this yet
yeah i'm usually live on twitter tv
slash equation
like most hours most days and uh that's
about it you can find me there
if you have any questions you can always
uh ask me there or at me on twitter
no doubt yeah salute ek man
love the story love love the energy love
what you're doing in the community the
vibes is super chill you know what i
mean
super knowledgeable on weapon reviews
too i love when you broke broke stuff
down i think i watched one of your um
deep stone [ __ ] uh raid weapon breakdown
yeah
all right there we go i love minutia
like that so just to see you go through
that
and then in the perks and stuff love
that keep up the good work man
absolutely fun yeah for me man cognito
on twitter you already know
and um i love podcasts every sunday the
lord's day check us out we can have our
chase money on sunday
so it'll be good kind of like fun
comedic streamer really cool vibes as
well
and then on saturday will be a special
edition
i love podcasts a big debate in the
community
and uh on in eve of the mass effect
trilogy
there is a big debate between which mass
effect is the best mass effect so
it's t mass effect one i'm on team mass
effect 2 we got some heavy hitters
coming to this debate that'll be
saturday 4 p.m eastern so if you're in
the mass effect
and you want to get hype to hit grown
men in their feelings about which one is
the best
check us out do you have a dog in this
fight because i've never played any of
them actually i'm
not out of this one
actually i'm curious about youtube
because you two are you know coming in
new so to speak so after you guys get
the trilogy i'm very curious to see
you know what what people do oh yeah
cognito's gonna be jumping at the bit to
know how i
how i feel when i play through the
remaster because it's gonna be the
refreshed it's not the ogs and that's
why he's doing the debate before the
refresh comes out
yeah so they can't polish up the first
one
the master effect one squad is we got
bro they got whole glow
they got bills still they got it they
got a they got an all-star team with
debaters so
we got to come correct you know what i'm
saying but shout out to like they got a
full-on attorney on their side so he
came
he came to argue so oh yeah he did
definitely do he shout out the whole
it's gonna be fun like i said if you
like that kind of stuff check it out
it'll be saturday
4pm oh we got two mass effect 2 votes in
there
you got a couple it's my kid like
what i'm talking about right let's go
let's go to what you eat uh yeah
resident evil 2 so i've got kind of the
weekend to myself my wife's going to
visit her family so i've got
resident evil 8 uh basically gonna blow
through that when i get up tomorrow
because i'm taking my wife to the
airport like 4 30 in the morning so i'm
gonna come home sleep
get up have breakfast and basically jump
back into that one on saturday
after that probably back into more
eternal because i do want to keep
pushing i got to the third world
nice god every every biome is like an
escalation you're like oh this can't get
this is okay this is insanely crazier so
third biome was kicking my butt a little
bit so working through that one
it's a hell of a game though i mean i
know it has had the bugs and some people
it's not for
everyone but it is a hell of a game that
they made and i'm glad
somebody was like yeah go ahead it's
like somebody releasing dark souls for
the first time it's like this is a third
person
arcade bullet hell shooter roguelike
and they're like yeah go go nuts and
they they did a really great job so far
the story is kind of intriguing very
curious what goes so
return will probably be like sunday and
stuff and then of course you guys know
tuesday we're all going to be
neck deep in destiny so that will be
fun um other than that i think we will
wrap this one up here
um but a big shout out to you ek equigan
is that the way to say it
yep okay um so
yeah just a pleasure to have the man
with the legendary golden vault it is
like since i've seen that tweet i was
like dude we have to get you on here
because that is
if nothing else like putting all my
vault to shame everybody's
oh your vault i'm like yeah mine's trash
this is actually full but for a good
reason so it's good to be there but no
it's like keep doing what you're doing
and believe me you are
you're an amazing piece of this
community and your community itself is
pretty amazing so
thank you for the all that you've done
for all the people out there you you put
in a lot of work and making people
very happy thank you man i appreciate
that
well for episode number one 48
that's where we're going to wrap this
thing up so thank you guys hopefully
have a good weekend check out all these
amazing gentlemen over there and down
there
saturdays sundays streaming podcasting
and all that good stuff but for this
episode
it has been the last word